So let's talk about some of the key
features that we have to implement.
Or some of the other functionality that
the Trusted Computing Base must have.
We have to have a complete mediation.
We have to guarantee that
there's no way to get to
a resource without going through
the trusted computing base, okay, or
the reference monitor
that it implements.
We have to have a trusted path.
Remember, trusted path is needed
because otherwise what could happen?
Well, some malicious program, a trojan
for example, can spoof the interface of
your trusted system and ultimate trusted
system is your trusted computing base.
So it could look like
the operating system and
you may think that the log in is being,
you're interacting with the OS.
A trusted path allows you to guarantee
that when you think you're talking
to the trusted computing base or
the operating system,
you indeed are talking to that system.
Which, of course, prevents programs,
malicious programs in particular,
Keyloggers.
A quick example of they're trying
to log your key strokes or
keys that you press to figure out
your password or whatever it is.
So, it prevents these kind of programs
from tapping the path from keyboard
where you press your keys to the system
where the key presses are captured.
This path has to be trusted,
and a result of that trust
is that malicious programs are not going
to be able to gain access to it and
be able to tap and see the information
that is being sent over it.
The next thing we have,
in terms of functionality features,
we didn't talk about that.
A lot of our focus has been on
the prevention side, the idea that,
you know, authentication makes
sure it's the right person.
Access control says the right
person gets access to
a resource that is getting requested.
The thing is that, no matter
how hard we work at prevention.
Things could go wrong.
Somebody can steal your password,
for example.
And they can login as you.
If we keep an audit log
of what has happened,
what objects have been accessed,
when, by whom.
Well this sort of an audit log can
come in handy when, and some abuse or
misuse might actually take place.
So, prevention, if it's not 100%,
then you have to go to detection, and
having a log will help
you with that detection.
Typically, detection is that for
some definition of unusual,
you see some unusual activity in
the system that potentially means
an attacker has gained access to it and
that unusual use can be,
an analysis that you do,
that detection is possible when you have
a recorder log of what the system did.
Keep in mind that this will only be
useful if we actually look at the log
and you're able to correctly
assess when there is an abuse.
So although audit, we're not going to
talk a great deal about that here,
but Lamson, one of the pioneers
who worked in security,
actually had this thing called
the gold standard of security.
This was based on the three AUs.
The authentication,
the authorization, and finally audit.
Periodic table symbol for gold is AU.
So the three AUs actually define
the gold standard for security.
And the third AU typically is
audit function that system.
So I said it's useful
only if you look at it,
but also it's only useful if malicious
programs are not able to tamper with it.
Okay, so it's integrity obviously
is going to be important.